[Aplausos]
ahora qué tal como están
bueno es un gusto verlos a todos aquí
siempre he sido fan de ted aunque
normalmente las únicas en boxers así que
de más por venir con pantalones
bueno como ya mencionaron yo soy grado
de ocasión de desarrollo de empresas la
carrera de casación y desarrollo de
empresas es un poco diferente a las
otras en el sentido de que pues tienes
que crear una empresa para graduarte no
yo les decía siempre mis amigos que el
éxito de las otras carreras normalmente
es qué tan rápido consigues chamba y el
éxito en creación es cuánto aguanta sin
tener chamba para seguir emprendiendo
esa es la pequeña diferencia entonces
cuando buscaba crear la presidencia
quiero aprender de los mejores y quiero
ir al ecosistema donde se crean la mayor
cantidad de empresas que impactan el
mundo y para mí eso es silicon valley
silicon valley es la región en san
francisco donde ha salido google
facebook apple y todas estas empresas
que impactan nuestra vida diaria tuve la
oportunidad cuando aplique para simular
este university simplemente university
con los a uno de mis compañeros es como
estar en vigo ver con personajes de the
big bang theory
y al final tienes que pinchar como en
sartén
y si les ganas tener la oportunidad
impactar un billón de personas esa es la
premisa y realmente estás rodeado de
gente brillante uno de mis compañeros
estaba iniciando la industria espacial
australiana de neutro que había vendido
una empresa en 200 millones de dólares y
otra chica que había hecho dos patentes
internacionales y ya había tomado clase
imagínate que
y también de salsa
pero ahí lo interesante era como podías
unir este talento para generar algo
genial y como poder utilizar este
talento para aplicarlo sobre una
tecnología exponencial
después se generará en una empresa y esa
empresa genera valor a la sociedad por
lo que hoy busco ser emprendedor
realmente qué es lo que hace que estas
empresas tengan éxito y qué es lo que
hace que estas compañías crean esta
tecnología
pues esto se lo debemos a una persona
llamada gordon moore que creó la ley de
moore y él se dio cuenta de que cada año
de los transistores los podía hacer a la
mitad del tamaño nos podía ser a la
mitad de precio y que fueran el doble de
rápido entonces lo que generó es que
cada vez la industria empezó a optimizar
para esto y ese personaje es el
cofundador de intel y esta tecnología lo
que permite es que si hace 20 años o 30
años la misma capaces de computación que
tenemos en un smartphone el día de hoy
valdría tres millones de dólares y
ahorita lo tienes por miles de pesos
y realmente casi cualquier persona tiene
un smartphone díaz en su bolsillo y esta
tecnología nos permite a nosotros
avanzar y crear nuevas propuestas de
valor
y realmente lo que ves más allá es que
si tú escalas de esta tecnología para el
año 2045 vamos a tener una computadora
de 1000 dólares con toda la capacidad de
computación de la raza humana
donde pensé en las implicaciones que se
va a tener en los proyectos que vamos a
poder hacer los problemas que vamos a
poder resolver lo que nuevas empresas
van a hacer de ahí
es por eso que regresando a méxico me
sentí un poquito como un incomprendido
es como que había bajado de una nave del
espacio y que la gente me escuchaba como
loco si tengo el cabello de genio loco
pero no era el punto
y que lo que hicimos creamos una empresa
para apoyar a muchos empresarios a que
conocieran qué es lo que está pasando en
esta tecnología y cómo se crea la
tecnología y esta empresa se llama una
máquina
gracias a más de cientos de empresarios
y emprendedores que hemos acompañado a
silicon valley nos hemos dado cuenta de
cuáles son las principales diferencias
que hay en ese ecosistema contra el
nuestro y cómo podemos nosotros como
emprendedores y como inversionistas
buscar mejorar este ecosistema para que
para tener más empresas que logren tener
estos
cuáles son las son las características
que hemos visto que nos ayudan a los
empresarios ya los inversionistas
mexicanos
número 1 es que buscamos ganancias en un
corto tiempo
muchas veces te dicen oye pero es que yo
quiero mirren dinero de regreso a los
dos años puestos que de joven no son
enchiladas tampoco no
los estados no son enchiladas y
realmente necesitamos tiempo de
maduración y que las empresas crestas el
siguiente punto es equívoca mentor ya no
hay una frase que me encanta que dicen
si un inversionista lo único que te da
es dinero te dio muy poco si lo que
buscas ser realmente alguien que te
apoye que te pueda decir cómo cómo
mejorar tu negocio que te pueden torear
después decir oye tengo este problema a
que presentó con alguien que te puede
ayudar a resolverlo
dt de esa red de contactos para hacer
que tu negocio mejore y prospere pero
sin llegar al punto que buscan muchos
que es buscar el control
muchas veces me ha tocado el típico caso
del empleador a veces y es que me quedan
invertir pero me dijeron que el 51% de
tu empresa porque porque quiero tomar
las decisiones
no
pero quiero tomar las decisiones
realmente ese es el primer problema
la diferencia de los inversionistas en
ecosistemas como san francisco como
silicon valley a lo que dicen es para
que quiero tener la mayoría yo prefiero
tener una parte pequeña porque al final
que la operar eres tú es que la operar
es el emprendedor él es el que tiene que
tomar la decisión y acaso contrario es
yo no voy a invertir en un emprendedor
que no tenga al menos el 30 por ciento
de su empresa porque tiene aquí te ha
iniciado un negocio
es una carrera exhaustiva y ustedes lo
saben realmente si no tienes tú un
incentivo real y te va a gratificar el
crear una empresa no lo va a hacer bien
y qué importa si yo como inversionista
le meto 100 pesos elemento 3 millones si
es emprendedor no tiene el incentivo y
no tiene las ganas no los incentivos
para que realmente sea que la empresa
adelante el dinero que le vas a poner no
va a valer y que te sirve tener 51 por
ciento de una empresa que no va a crecer
y que te sienta el 70 por ciento de un
empresa que no lo crees
y esa es la principal diferencia busquen
tener tal vez un porcentaje minoritario
pero una empresa de este tamaño
y tal vez no te van a pedir dividendos
como lo hacen aquí que es oye pues cada
año quiero que me des mi cheque hay al
contrario lo que te dicen es oye si
quieres en vez de que me den los dedos
para que una hora no reinvierte solo a
la empresa porque a mí lo que me
interesa es que hagas que la empresa
crezca y que realmente sea un pastel
mucho más grande que después podamos
vender y salga la web entonces el
problema aquí es que muchas veces
buscamos ángeles inversionistas y
también nos topamos con un inversionista
no
así que qué es lo que buscamos en el
ecosistema y cómo podemos mejorar un
ecosistema de innovación y porque
funciona un ecosistema como silicon
valley como israel como algunos otros
que están más desarrollados es como el
ciclo básicamente del agua
muy parecido porque tienes emprendedores
que inician y van empezando con su idea
la validando y llegan algunos
inversionistas ángeles les ponen un poco
de capital semilla y quiénes son estos
primeros inversionistas ángeles es lo
que les llaman los amigos la familia y
en inglés le llama la triple fe que es
price familiar falsos a los tontos ya
vemos los fans
porque ella es muy muy fácil es muy
conocido que la gente conozca estos
temas y es muy fácil que tú primera
ronda la levantes con tus amigos y la
inversión principal que le van a poner
no es al negocio si no es a ti te van a
apoyar a ti y es parte de la sociedad
del apoyar a otros emprendedores que
también están buscando lo mismo tú tú
porque también están buscando crecer en
el mismo amigo tuyo
siguió eso pues vas trabajando algunos
de ellos van a fracasar es natural y el
inversionista lo sabe de 10 a 20
proyectos van a fracasar ellos buscan el
uno o dos proyectos que tengan éxito y
qué va a pasar con esos emprendedores
que fracasan regresan al ciclo y vuelven
a empezar muchos y el inversionista aquí
cuando algo así pasa artistas que y me
toca escuchar los emprendedores que me
dieron un poco de dinero y les ganó
sabes que eres lo peor que me ha pasado
en la vida
y qué pasa con los inversionistas en el
público maniquís a ánimo preocupes
cuando tengas una siguiente idea ven
conmigo porque porque ya saben que ya
tienes una experiencia y ya sabes que ya
perdiste que no tienes que hacer para
crear una startup
y más cuales odio lo ven como que al
invertir en un estado que fracasó la
siguiente que tenga éxito quiere estar
ahí también
después que pasa de estos emprendedores
los que pasan a la siguiente ronda
digamos no ha sido la empresa que
empieza a crecer endesa tener éxito y
tracción ya llegan otro tipo de
servicios que los apoyan llegan los
bancos llegan los inversionistas y van
creciendo con él con estos emprendedores
y al final lo que sucede es que estos
emprendedores cuando logran tener éxito
salen a la bolsa y es cuando se vende la
empresa sale una bolsa o los compro
alguna otra empresa y qué es lo que pasa
con ellos empiezan a retornar ese
capital y vuelve a empezar el ciclo y se
vuelve un círculo virtuoso y no
solamente eso sino que ellos saben que
la herramienta más poderosa para
reclutar gente de talento está en que
ellos también sean dueños de la empresa
entonces la mayoría de los núcleos que
entraron en las primeras etapas cuando
uno se vendió visión entre dos a tres
millones de dólares en volumen y qué
pasó con muchos de ellos empezaron a
fondos de inversión o salieron empezaron
a hacer a emprender otros negocios les
digo tenemos por ejemplo a bismarck lepe
que fue de los primeros googlers y
después de que se vendió la empresa
ahora tiene white knight en guadalajara
entonces se puede destilar este
ecosistema en dos palabras para mí es
colaboración y arman
así que la próxima vez te puedes apoyar
a algún amigo tuyo que tengas si puedes
invertir en el que pueden entregarlo
piensa en la manera que puedes hacer que
a todos les vaya bien en este ecosistema
porque es la única manera en la que
vamos a hacer que este ecosistema
christina muchas gracias
[Aplausos]